how powerful is Razer is it lots is it
not lots is it somewhere in between
could Razer defeat the Phantom troop
could raise a b to battle clown well how
about a royal guard Hunter Hunter is a
notoriously difficult series to power
scale but razor mate Razer he may be the
hardest character of all because on
paper what he's demonstrated may as well
be a top 5 nen user in the series and
I'm not exaggerating at all I think that
under the right conditions he could beat
a royal guard but don't let this weirdly
awkward figure that somehow made it past
product testing fool you Razer is a nen
Behemoth and much of that has to do with
a certain Jing freaks Razer
interestingly enough spent more time
being raised by Jinx than gone spent
being raised by jing a dodgeball
Enthusiast actually has a bit of a dark
background having been abused as a
childbling and growing up with this
mentality that he was a good for nothing
loser Slowpoke lame-o oxygen thieving
undercooked potato salad that nobody
wants at Christmas lunch just to name a
few there were more and as a result of
this Razer not so unpredictably turns to
a life of crime so amassed some pretty
serious crime as well throughout his
criminal years Razer kill murdered
multiple people and was eventually
caught and sentenced to death and the
reason why I'm going through his
background isn't just a fill time in the
video it's important to know because Nan
prowess is directly linked to drive and
desire so knowing people's backgrounds
is much more insightful than most Power
Systems enter Jing freaks a man whose
primary skill lies Less in nen Mastery
and More in manipulating others for his
own personal means in this case Jing
offered razor an opportunity Razer could
either follow a stranger to a remote
island to enact vague plans or he could
be executed it wasn't really a choice
and you shouldn't really follow strange
men to strange Islands but Razer did
meant to be fair and worked out pretty
well and Razer grew to seriously respect
Ching having had his entire drive and
desire transformed and focused towards
realizing Jing's project of Greed Island
with Razer going on to spend 13 years on
the island as one of its 11 game Masters
I'll say that again he has been on Greed
Island for 13 years which means that
he's been a nen user for at least 13
years and not just any end user but a
pupil of the greatest identified nen
Genius of this generation in order to
implement what is to this day the most
complex example of nen use in the world
granted it was all in service of a game
but razer's development was pretty
seriously fast-tracked mostly because
that's the only way Jing does things and
needs to be quick and efficient so he
can abandon it and move on to the next
thing but Razer himself serves as the
game master of emissive systems in his
words I make most spells work which to
put into some perspective there are 40
spell cards available to players on
Greed Island and an unknown number of
special game Master Spells such as
eliminate and while spells are
definitely not the most powerful cards
in greed Islands those would be the
restrictor cards but spells are
certainly the most commonly used cards
they are the essential utility of the
game the lifeblood and look I'm gonna go
ahead and blow your mind now with what
we know of the cards alone Razer
technically possesses at least 41 unique
none abilities because each of those
cards is a separate and unique power
tapping in to raises Affinity of
emission and that that's a lot of
abilities and without knowing exactly
which game a masters handle which are
the cards at the moment it comfortably
makes Razer the person in the series
with by far the most heartsu I mean
there's a reason why Razer can confront
half of the Phantom troop dressed in gym
shorts and still cause Sphinx to
immediately quake in his tracksuit this
is also where Razer tells her tells a
bit of a naughty lie as well he states
that it's been years since anyone
entered the island illegally and yet at
this time he had also very recently
evicted crawler as well as for an actual
demonstration of power though I present
to you dodgeball Razer quite casually
confronted the Menage arcade that is
gone kilua and hisoka no it wasn't a
standard nen battle but he still tanked
three phenomenally talented ore users in
fact it's actually a much better Display
of Power than a standard fight because
gone's greatest of talents lies in his
sheer Aura quantity he has such a high
quantity of stuff that he can make the
biggest of booms so this dodgeball match
was actually fighting under gon's ideal
conditions because both he and Razer
were having a role back and forth
slugfest of who can handle the most Aura
infused impacts and because it's such a
simple Affair we can actually use this
as a practical guide for raises or
output knuckle estimated gone's total
Aura at 21 500 units with the
individually charged tax like rock
utilizing somewhere between 1800 to just
over 2 000 units each and just the
thought of being thwacked by a power
like that was enough to make knuckle
faint and even Mara was shocked and had
just a little bit of pee coming out when
he was confronted with this ability but
Razer he continuously tanked and even
throughout his own Equitable attacks and
by the end of the match he was still
just getting warmed up content to
continue volleying until one side lost
the battle of attrition and from this
very straightforward fight we can infer
that Razor's Aura output is an order of
magnitude above that of gaunt at least
twice perhaps even three times as much
especially considering that at the time
his Aura was also powering the game as
well as his nen beasts use for the match
and speaking of that's something we
should note Razer ability number 42 is a
fully realized hatsu called 14 Devils
which is extremely impressive in its own
right with Razer being able to summon a
series of n base with Fusion
capabilities whereas most NBC users tend
to focus on summoning one or two the
most comparable power we probably have
is shot mono's 11 black children which
were highly highly disappointing basic
and nion useless puppets and I guess if
you count the basic horrible then Razer
has 43 separate none abilities at least
meanwhile his stats according to the
data book are extraordinary achieving 4
out of five in literally every area
which places raises overall rating above
characters like even nov and moral I use
those two because they're very much the
gold standard of hunters everything
above the two of them is just plain
surpassing human limits probably best
displayed by the stats of the royal
guards who achieve a perfect five in
almost everything with a couple of
lingering threes and fours depending on
which one it is you're talking about so
Razer fit somewhere between moral and
the royal guard which sounds pretty damn
amazing but we have some caveats because
razors truly mind-brainingly boggling
power can only be achieved through a
heavily heavily detrimental limitation
in fact limitations plural as the
character width by far the most
abilities in the series Razer holds
another title of being by far the most
restricted nen user in the series
because on great Island Razer may be
nion Invincible it would take someone
like marowam to crack Razer in home
territory outside of great Island that's
a very different matter though so let's
talk about spells first there they have
a lot of restrictions one spells can
only be used on Greed Island with a
sub-restriction that a player must have
entered through the appropriate game
entrance two spells can only be acquired
in the spell card shop three they can
only be purchased in randomized packs
four with the exception of game
MasterCard spells can only be used by
legal players AKA not Razer himself 5.
to activate a spell one must hold it in
their hand say the name of said spell
and then on six spells must have a legal
Target seven spell cards vanished once
used and eight spells have further
individual restrictions depending upon
the exact mechanics and how they
interact with other potential defensive
spells wow that was a lot I'm kind of
out of breath so that's at least eight
limitations we need to lay right down to
use any one of those abilities so it's
not so much that razor has these Godly
levels of horror quantity it's more so
that he's managing to multiply the
effect by truly stupid numbers for
example let's say a basic person spends
20 units of Aura for an ability with 20
units of output what Razer does here is
he spends 20 units of Aura multiplies it
by eight limitations and that results in
160 units of output I mean that's a very
simplified way to look at it I'm sure
that the fictional maths is much more
complex than that but now let's address
attack tanking because razer's most
impressive Feats are repeatedly taking
direct dodgeball hits from Gone the
thing about this though is that Razer
always knew exactly where the DodgeBall
was going to go the principle of the
match meant that he and gone were just
going to keep flinging attacks in the
exact same spot until one of them was
beaten or dead or both maybe both and
that's a big Advantage because it allows
Razer to know exactly where to focus his
defenses whereas in the case of knuckle
he fainted because he did not know where
gone was going to attack and knuckle
knew that if he chose the incorrect
location to focus his Aura then he was
just flat out going to die if Nako had a
100 percent guarantee then he could have
comfortably defended but with that said
I don't think that knuckle could have
done it repeatedly like Razer did and
then we have the Devils disregarding
everything else that Razer is capable of
the 14 Devils is a top tier heartsu in
its own right but given that power I
feel like it can only be allowed to
exist through limitations and my
hypothesis here is that the 14 Devils
were created for the sole purpose of
Razer being able to field a team for the
plot of beach challenge he needed to
make sure that he would always be able
to field a dodgeball team ideally
without relying on all of the
untrustworthy bungle nuts around him and
also Razer needs to use one of the
Devils as the referee there is a further
restriction that raises Aura get split
amongst each devil created so it's a
very significant cost to make these dude
guys which almost makes razer's
performance that much more impressive
because for most of the game he is only
using a minor percentage of his total
available Aura for himself but I suspect
that this ability can only be used for
the plot of beach challenge otherwise
it's just way too strong there's also a
very intriguing battle clown interaction
here which is that hisoka had no desire
desire to fight razor so he may very
well have understood just how restricted
Razer was and chose to confront him on
the battlefield that is dodgeball aka
the only place that hisoka would be able
to experience Rey's full raziness and
hisoka actually does go on to stay
afterwards I just had a very fun battle
The Rush has left me sensitized to
soothe my arousal I wouldn't mind
ravaging someone I don't know so he um
well he clearly got something out of
razor and he also says this whilst
holding a very phallic telescope in
between his legs other than look there's
something going on there but Razer is
very much defined by his role in Greed
Island he has immense insane power but
only for these hyper-specific purposes
specific purposes such as dodgeball in
fact Razer is so defined by dodgeball
that the hunter hunter card game
features over 40 individual razor cards
and of those only four of them feature
Razer not playing dodgeball he is easily
the most boring character in the game
given that everyone else gets beach
wedding Halloween and all sorts of other
crazy variants as a whole we should also
acknowledge that nen inscription is is a
huge part of what powers Greed Island
those are the funky circuit board
looking markings that you see when you
initially enter the island it's a
mysterious nen code that serves the
overall purpose of boosting power to be
fair we don't know if Frieza personally
benefits from this but Greed Island
definitely does and Razer All Things
Considered is a well above average nen
user his Aura quantity well exceeds that
of the natural talent that is gone and
may even be more comparable to someone
like Morrow within Greed Island Razer
multiplies his power exponentially with
the most restrictions we've ever seen in
the series and on this island Razer
could even be considered a top 5 nen
user I would not at all be surprised to
see a royal guard struggle or even lose
to Razer on Greed Island outside of
great Island they clear him but even in
the very worst case scenario Razer is
still a world-class nen user were he not
sentenced to carry out the whims of Jing
he could be someone well worthy of
joining the ranks of the Phantom troop
or even the zodiacs but still the fact
remains that inside of great Island
Razer is practically a god